craziest thing you you've got to slash  had to do jump off a building  how big of a building we're talking here  40 I'm going to guess around 46 stories  yeah but really jump off the building  Yeah well yeah jump off because so much  of the movie is digital why do they make  you jump off a real building because  it's Lana machowski and it's the Matrix  and you need natural light and you want  to do it real I mean there's wires and  how do you feel about Heights they get  me a little like I don't know what  happens when you get old when you when  you're on Heights and you start getting  attracted to like wanting to jump what  is that that is that is a reason to seek  help  how many times did you have to do it  well we wanted to do in the perfect  light in in the morning and so we did it  I would say around 19 20 times